Trascrizione: Martina Dusi
Revisore: Sara Leonetti
Nei prossimi 18 minuti,
il vostro cervello
verrà hackerato più e più volte.
In solo due di queste
non sarete voi a farlo.
Ma c'è di più:
queste intrusioni
non avranno nulla a che fare
con questioni di tipo etico, legale
o di buona educazione.
Non necessiteranno
di autorizzazioni particolari,
o di domande specifiche.
E non saranno visibili
perché accadendo qui dentro,
è difficile vederci qualcosa.
O forse no?
Oggi, con le nuove raffinate tecniche
di neuroimaging funzionale,
è possibile vedere e valutare un cervello
e le sue differenti funzionalità.
Per fare questo, però, c'è bisogno
necessariamente di due cose:
un cervello, oggetto non scontato
e recentemente
neanche così disponibile;
e uno scanner RMF,
un oggetto che nemmeno
è scontato
l'avremmo potuto portare qui dentro oggi
per riuscire a vedere tutti i
vostri cervelli in attività.
Perché di cervelli in attività,
qui dentro, ne abbiamo tanti:
ma manchiamo di uno scanner.
Allora vi propongo un sistema
per portar fuori i vostri neuroni
dalla vostra scatola cranica,
senza spargimento di sangue.
Per cortesia fate così:
provate ad allungare
un braccio davanti a voi.
Ottimo. Questa è una perfetta
rappresentazione di un neurone,
con: il nucleo. al centro
del vostro palmo;
le dita, i dendriti,
che ricevono i segnali dall'esterno
e li processano lungo l'assone
all'interno di un centro di elaborazione.
Se alzate un po' la manica
potete anche vedere la guaina mielinica
e le cellule di Schwann,
più o meno pelose.
Ma proviamo a vedere
un po' meglio, nel dettaglio,
questa meravigliosa macchina
come funziona.
Quindi vi chiedo, in questo momento,
di fare esattamente
quello che vi chiedo di fare:
alzatevi tutti in piedi.
Allungate le due braccia
davanti a voi - ottimo -
oh, così ci vediamo anche meglio;
e muovete le dita in questo modo:
muovete, muovete...
Eccoli, questi sono i neuroni
che stanno rispondendo
a una stimolazione vocale,
quella che io vi sto comunicando;
e lo fanno in modo molto rispondente
e con nessuna morte cerebrale in sala.
Molto bene. - (Risate)
Ora continuate a fare esattamente
quello che vi dico di fare:
fermate le vostre dita,
volgete le mani dorso contro dorso,
alzate la mano destra,
ponetela sopra la mano sinistra,
congiungete i palmi delle mani,
intrecciate le dita
e fate molta attenzione
che il pollice della mano sinistra -
la mano sinistra, quella che era
sotto la mano destra: ecco, esatto -
sia preso tra il pollice della mano destra
e l'indice della mano destra
poi allungate gli indici
e stringete forte i polpastrelli
Guardateli, eccoli:
questi sono due neuroni
che stanno costruendo
una trasmissione sinaptica.
Neuroni che rispondono ad un segnale,
mentre altri neuroni hanno appena subito
il primo attacco hacker,
che è andato a buon fine
se non riuscite a fare così
(Risate)
(Applausi)
Voi, sono certo, sono sicuro
che avete immaginato di rispondere
a delle indicazioni che provenivano
da davanti ai vostri occhi,
da dalle immagini che erano
davanti ai vostri occhi,
mentre i vostri neuroni rispondevano;
ma forse non è proprio così.
In effetti, noi vediamo
ciò che vogliamo vedere,
quello che ci aspettiamo di vedere
mentre la nostra attenzione
non riesce a cogliere cose
là dove avvengono azioni e cambiamenti
che passano sotto la nostra soglia
di consapevolezza.
Questo significa che noi
reagiamo a degli stimoli
non tanto della realtà oggettiva
che arriva alla nostra percezione
quanto ad un'immagine mentale
che ci costruiamo.
Un'immagine mentale
che ci crea delle idee,
o appunto delle immagini,
che mettono in comunicazione
qualcosa che sta fuori
con qualcosa che sta dentro.
E lavorano con qualcuno che sta
o dal lato nostro, o contro di noi.
"Noi vediamo ciò
che ci aspettiamo di vedere"
significa che nella maggior parte
delle nostre scelte quotidiane
siamo "liberamente obbligati",
ovvero pensiamo in base
a quello che già crediamo
mentre ci sentiamo liberi
di governare il nostro pensiero.
Il nostro sistema hackerato
ha già preso una decisione per noi,
mettendo lui in relazione la realtà
con la nostra mente.
Il nostro modo
di relazionarci con la realtà
non passa sempre
per il sentiero più lineare, logico
e razionale che possiamo immaginare,
quanto per dei percorsi emotivi
che sono caratterizzati
da euristiche e bias,
fallacie percettive
e illusioni del nostro pensiero.
Ma chi è che ci illude?
Sicuramente, qualcuno che viene da fuori
o qualcosa che viene da fuori:
il mercato, le informazioni,
la pubblicità;
ma [anche], molto spesso,
qualcosa che viene da dentro.
In effetti, la comunicazione
ci può ingannare;
ma anche la nostra mente... mente,
o meglio, la nostra mente ci mente.
Il fatto è
che noi affidiamo alla nostra mente
ciò che vogliamo fortemente credere.
Ma cosa significa credere?
L'origine della parola credere
ci rimanda alla parola "credito".
Se noi abbiamo fiducia
nella nostra mente
è perché diamo credito ad essa;
e allo stesso modo, alla stessa maniera,
se ci fidiamo della realtà
è perché crediamo a quello
a cui essa ci rimanda.
Queste, realtà e mente, sono due
delle tre facce della medaglia.
C'è poi quella che io chiamo
la terza faccia della medaglia.
La terza faccia,
ovvero la terza metà,
è quel luogo
in cui noi siamo "liberamente obbligati"
nelle nostre decisioni.
È quel luogo in cui noi spendiamo
il nostro "credito relazionale":
non solo nelle nostre
relazioni economiche,
ma anche nelle nostre relazioni umane!
Essere obbligati, liberamente obbligati,
significa ob-ligati, legati insieme,
o meglio è la nostra mente che ci obbliga,
che ci lega alle sue proprie decisioni.
Facciamo un gioco!
Prendete una penna e un foglietto di carta
che avete trovato, al rientro dalla pausa,
nella vostra borsa.
Grazie.
Come vedete, questa è la parte
più articolata della presentazione:
riuscire a recuperare, in quel sacco,
la penna - ottimo - e un foglio di carta.
Pubblico: Va bene anche rosso?
MB: Qualsiasi colore.
Ce l'avete in mano?
Ora, durante il gioco che vi propongo,
su quel foglietto di carta
potete già iniziare a scrivere
una lista di quattro numeri
in colonna, in questo modo:
uno, due, tre e quattro.
Accanto a ciascun numero, tra poco,
scriverete una risposta molto rapida,
quanto rapida è la domanda che io vi farò.
prima però mettiamoci d'accordo
su quelle che sono
le regole di questo gioco.
Come in tutti i giochi, ci sono
delle regole da rispettare.
Prima regola:
per cortesia,
quando individuerete la risposta
alla domanda, nella vostra mente,
trascrivetela su quel foglio;
e poi, alla fine del gioco -
e vi dirò io quando il gioco finisce -
leggerete, qua e là, alcune risposte
senza modificare quanto scritto.
La prima regola possiamo riassumerla
con il "non barate".
È chiara?
È chiara.
Seconda regola: da questo momento in poi
non si possono più fare domande
È chiara la seconda regola?
(Pubblico): sì
MG: Sì è una risposta:
ottimo, ci siamo.
Terza regola e ultima:
da questo momento in poi,
fino a quando finirà questo gioco
non si può più ridere.
Se qualcuno contravviene
a una di queste regole, o più,
non è un problema: gira il foglio,
e lascia giocare gli altri.
Ok? Iniziamo.
Per cortesia, rispondete a questa domanda:
quante sigarette ci sono
in un pacchetto?
Scritto?
Seconda domanda: quante sigarette ci sono
in un pacchetto di sigarette?
Scritto?
Terza domanda: quante sigarette ci sono
in un pacchetto di sigarette intatto?
Annotato?
Quarta e ultima domanda.
Per cortesia, rispondete a questa domanda:
quante sigarette ci sono
in questo pacchetto di sigarette?
Scritto?
Il gioco è finito,
potete ridere - (Ride)
così ci liberiamo di un po' di ansia;
e soprattutto potete ridere di gusto
adesso che vedrete quante volte
la vostra mente ha hackerato se stessa.
Partiamo dalla prima domanda:
quante sigarette ci sono in un pacchetto?
Che cosa avete risposto?
No, non serve che me lo diciate:
queste macchine sono dei libri aperti,
di fronte a degli hacker cognitivi.
Tant'è vero che voi vi siete sentiti,
o la maggior parte di voi si è sentita,
libera di rispondere in modo generale,
a questa domanda,
scrivendo numeri che vanno
da zero a venti,
o un numero qualsiasi da zero a venti,
o risposte del tipo: "Dipende, non lo so.
Quante ne sono state fumate,
prima di portarlo sul palco?"
mentre eravate già
inconsapevolmente obbligati
a costruire una risposta
da un'associazione tra sigarette
e pacchetti di sigarette.
Il vostro sistema, già hackerato,
vi stava tenendo lontano da una realtà,
seppur verosimile e plausibile.
Infatti, chi di voi, alla domanda:
"Quante sigarette
ci sono in un pacchetto?
ha, ad esempio, pensato
ad un pacchetto tipo questo?
Oppure ad un pacchetto tipo questo?
Alcuno.
È la dimostrazione che il vostro sistema
era già stato hackerato
da quello che si chiama "bias di conferma"
Seconda domanda: quante sigarette ci sono
in un pacchetto di sigarette?
Cosa avete scritto?
Non serve rispondere,
siete già stati hackerati!
Giusto, ve lo ricordate?
Qui, lungo i sentieri della comunicazione
liberamente obbligante,
iniziata nell'elencazione§
delle tre norme -
seppur paradossali,
come quella di non ridere,
e dalla prima domanda,
ecco che ha costruito,
ha confermato quell'inferenza:
che se stiamo parlando
di pacchetti e di sigarette,
e addirittura poi ci dicono
di pacchetti di sigarette,
be', allora mi sto riferendo
proprio a delle immagini
dei pacchetti di sigarette.
Qualcuno di voi nella seconda domanda
ha quindi - o la maggior parte di voi -
ripetuto la risposta data alla prima,
oppure l'ha leggermente
aggiornata, aggiustata.
È quella che si chiama
"euristica dell'ancoraggio
e dell'aggiustamento"
È la stessa che funziona
quando, ad esempio, ci ancoriamo
al primo prezzo comunicato
in una negoziazione commerciale;
oppure quando cerchiamo -
proviamoci insieme, a rispondere
a questa domanda:
quanti sono, il numero
più preciso possibile,
i migranti extraeuropei
che sono arrivati in Italia nel 2017?
Mentre state cercando quel numero,
il vostro sistema hackerato
sta tenendo lontana dalla vostra risposta,
la raffigurazione, ad esempio,
di un broker finanziario di Zurigo
che si è appena trasferito
nella City di Milano,
oppure di uno chef stellato giapponese,
extracomunitario
che ha trovato lavoro, stabile, a Roma.
Quest'inferenza, questo sistema
di inferenze, cresce man mano
e si rinforza con la terza domanda.
Quando infatti parliamo
di pacchetti intatti,
a cosa ci stiamo riferendo?
Ci stiamo riferendo a quell'esperienza
che noi abbiamo di pacchetti,
che abbiamo visto, che abbiamo vissuto.
Ecco allora che andiamo
a cercare la risposta -
o meglio, il nostro hacker
viola i nostri sistemi mnemonici,
scardina i riferimenti
della nostra esperienza
e ci fa scrivere numeri
tipo 10, 20, 25. Giusto?
Cioè, pescando quello
che è più rappresentativo,
quello che è più disponibile in memoria:
si chiama "euristica della disponibilità"
Vado a pescare la risposta
là dove ho un vissuto particolare.
Quindi potrei rispondere 35?
Sì, se sono appena tornato,
ad esempio, dall'Australia
e al duty free ho comprato
un pacchetto intatto, incellofanato,
che contiene 35 sigarette.
Ma la questione è:
se io avessi risposto 19,
avreste accettato questa risposta?
19? Sì!
Se fossi disposto
a spostare un po' più in là
i limiti della mia esperienza
di riferimento
per trovare una risposta corretta
alla terza domanda
riferendomi ad esempio
a pacchetti di sigarette
legalmente venduti
nelle tabaccherie di Londra.
Ma veniamo alla quarta domanda:
quante sigarette ci sono
in questo pacchetto di sigarette?
È possibile trovare una risposta corretta,
giusta, a questa domanda?
Oppure, dopo che il nostro sistema
è stato hackerato,
questa possibilità è svanita, sfumata?
Perché? Perché in effetti lì,
su quel foglietto di carta,
voi avete iniziato a confermare
un'immagine mentale
che vi ha tenuti lontano,
anche nel momento in cui
ce l'avevate di fronte agli occhi,
dalla realtà dei pacchetti di sigarette.
O sbaglio?
Rispondere in modo giusto
alla quarta domanda
significa abbandonare l'immagine mentale
che ho dei pacchetti di sigarette.
Significa non ascoltare la voce suadente
che risponde senza nemmeno guardarlo,
quel problema.
Significa riuscire a toglierci
dall'ancora dei nostri schemi mentali,
che sono rappresentati oggi
da quelle sedie
ma che ogni giorno sono rappresentati
dalle nostre modalità decisionali
nelle quali viviamo,
ed essere capaci di controllare
le violazioni e le intromissioni
di questi sistemi hackeranti,
di queste modalità
di controllo della mente,
che vengono da noi stessi.
È infatti la nostra mente che ci obbliga,
che ci rende "liberamente obbligati"
nelle nostre scelte.
Ed è il nostro comportamento
che sta sotto il rischio,
sempre più frequente,
di essere hackerati da noi stessi
molto di più di quanto pensiamo.
Noi conviviamo con un hacker interno.
Allora, mi piacerebbe che ci portassimo
a casa, da questa esperienza,
tre sneakers, tre programmi,
che permettano al nostro caro hacker
non solo di essere
più consapevole dei propri limiti,
ma anche di avere qualche strumento in più
per migliorare le nostre
decisioni quotidiane:
in campo relazionale, umano;
e in campo economico, sociale.
E in quello che vi caratterizza di più
nelle vostre professionalità,
e nella vostra quotidianità.
Primo sneaker:
dubitare delle informazioni,
così come vi sono date dall'esterno,
così come sono create dall'interno,
verificarle.
Secondo sneakes:
valorizzare l'errore,
perché se è vero
che è la nostra mente
che ci rende "liberamente obbligati"
be', almeno che lo sia
nella direzione sempre più opportuna.
E infine, terzo sneaker:
be', evitare di fumare -
(Risate)
ma ricordarci di non solo aprire la mente,
ma di aprire, anche,
tutti i pacchetti di sigarette
che ci troveremo di fronte.
Grazie.
(Applausi)